beautiful as we look out over the skies
this morning we do have some high clouds
out there they're kind of rotating in
off the southern California coast I'll
show you those on the satellite in a
moment just updated all the valley
temperatures again this is not the time
to be Watering your lawn if it's your
watering day so make sure those are set
during the warmth of the day with full
on sunshine or even right around noon is
a good time it's freezing in Nellis
below freezing in Seven Hills Kyle
Canyons had some Breezy winds up there
winds have been over 20 miles an hour
teens in Caliente we've got 20s in
Mesquite Kingman Sandy Valley Indian
Springs and Pahrump it's just darn cold
we'll be looking for good Sunshine
through the day though after these high
clouds most of them are just going to
fall apart we're not going to get much
of them 54 for the high normal high is
56. I want to give a shout out to folks
who really look out after their pets
whether they're indoors or outdoors and
this is from Davey Matthews who tends to
feral cats in her outdoor setting in
Pahrump they won't come indoors because
they're wild cats but if they're spayed
and neutered and she puts out pet
heating pads on her patio and has Kitty
Condos for them so thank you Davey look
at them aren't they sweet well cared 40
and she even has heated water bowls for
the cats and the birds in their yard so
that's awfully nice thanks Davey for
sharing that do all you can for the pets
who can't come inside all right we've
got more rain moving through the eastern
U.S from that large system and freezing
rain over the Northeast more snow in the
north and high pressure over our area
Will Keep Us cold here there are those
clouds off the southern California coast
but again we're not going to see too
many of those today we'll call it sunny
breezy tomorrow with another disturbance
will cool us down to start the weekend
down to 49 for Saturday but look at that
warming Trend next week as we head
towards Christmas might even make it to
the low 60s on our second day of winter
next week